[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue en point de vue
ravi de vous retrouver pour notre rendez
vous quotidien nous allons traiter
quatre sujets qu'on va découvrir tout de
suite en images
finalement le gouvernement n'a pas
présenté hier deux plans contre les
violences à l'école il paraît que les
ministres sont pas tout à fait d'accord
entre eux d'où notre question
le gouvernement est il assez sévère face
aux violences des jeunes nous allons
parler de ségolène royal aussi qui sort
aujourd'hui un livre qui s'appelle ce
que je peux enfin vous dire
elle explique tout ce qu'elle a dû subir
parce que c'était une femme est ce que
cette victimisation est une stratégie
gagnante on en parlera et puis jupiter a
besoin de vacances le président de la
république va s'arrêter pendant trois
jours il paraît qu'ils pas en normandie
est-ce que c'est inquiétant ou est ce
que c'est juste normal qu'il soit
fatigué vous lui donnerez votre point de
vue et puis aujourd'hui c'est halloween
demain c'est la toussaint alors
choisissez votre camp vous êtes plutôt
halloween toussaint évidemment on va
élargir un peu le sujet pour
s'interroger sur le rapport qu'ont les
français avec leur défunt bonsoir clark
et vous êtes très inscrit son chef des
pages idées de l'express l'express qui
publie cette semaine en couverture un
formidable dossier sur les parents
d'élèves qui abusent et qui se croit un
peu tout permet en tout cas si on en
croit les témoignages de profs qui sont
dans votre magazine gaspard grandir elle
a aussi bon soir cet ancien responsable
de la communication de françois hollande
vous êtes aussi l'auteur d'un livre la
politique est un sport de combat
publié chez fayard vous êtes le
fondateur de parisienne parisien et vous
êtes presque candidat à la mairie de
paris xavier couture elle a aussi
bonsoir bonsoir ravi de vous voir vous
êtes conseiller audiovisuel vous avez
été patron de plaintes chaînes de
télévision et vous êtes polémiste à
orphée le monde j'ai le confrère t elle
ça m'arrive et frédéric dabi et là aussi
bon soir frédéric pour se recueillir
ravis de vous accueillir vous êtes
politologue tout le monde le sait et
vous êtes directeur général adjoint de
l'ifop
alors on commence par ce sujet des
violences des jeunes
après les images qui avaient fait le
tour du web de cette professeure menacée
un de ses élèves qui brandissait un
pistolet factice on nous avait annoncé
un plan sur les violences à l'école
finalement il y aura pas de plan en tout
cas pas tout de suite c'est pour le 15
décembre
mais jean michel blanquer a quand même
pris la parole aujourd'hui pour parler
du projet qu'il avait déjà annoncé de
mettre des policiers dans les écoles et
bien finalement le ministre de
l'éducation nationale il est très très
très prudent la possibilité d'une
permanence d'un policier ou d'un
gendarme
à la demande du chef d'établissement
lorsque le contexte le nécessite bien
sûr il ne s'agit pas contrairement à ce
que j'ai pu entendre d'en mettre partout
dans tout établissement toute école n'a
jamais été l'idée ça ne le sera par
contre c'est la possibilité de le faire
à la demande du chef d'établissement qui
existe et selon des durées qui sont à
décider entre l'établissement et une
institution que ce soit la police ou la
gendarmerie
alors c'est pas rétro pédalage mais
quand même on sent que il veut pas y
aller trop fort le ministre de
l'éducation nationale sa sortie est ce
que c'est une erreur d'analysé où le
gouvernement est quand même un peu gêné
sur ce dossier je pense parce que en
plus ils savent bien que la surenchère
sécuritaire en matière de violence
scolaire est pas forcément la réponse
c'est plus une rustine à mon sens que
d'évoquer des policiers à l'intérieur de
l'établissement
plus une rustine qu'autre chose et en
plus ça met l'accent sur la violence
dans l'établissement scolaire avant
alors qu'il faudrait la mettre le maître
cet accent sur l'enseignement et sur le
fond le vrai problème
dans les établissements le vrai problème
autour de la violence scolaire
il se situe pas là où on pense on pense
que les enseignants sont aujourd'hui
malmenée en fait on s'aperçoit depuis le
raid
oui tout à fait mais d'après eric
debarbieux qui est la référence en la
matière en matière de violence scolaire
qui a fait un très gros travail dans
kate c'est dernières années en fait on
s'aperçoit que le pourcentage de
professeurs qui s'estiment qui ont le
sentiment vraiment d'être malmenés ne
bouge pas ne varie pas il est aux
alentours de 16 % ce qui pose beaucoup
plus de problème c'est le manque de
respect des règles de discipline à
l'intérieur des établissements
ce sont les bagarres les insultes tout
ce genre de choses est en fait la
réponse à ce genre de problème c'est pas
forcément des policiers c'est beaucoup
plus une stratégie commune dans chaque
établissement qui doit être mise en
place en fait entre tous les acteurs
tous les professionnels moi j'ai vu ça
très concrètement lorsque je couvrais
l'éducation à l'express pendant
plusieurs années
donc en fait il faut que tous aient la
même réponse face à l'indiscipliné et
sage par exemple tous se mettre d'accord
sur ce qui est tolérable et ce qui ne
l'est pas à l'intérieur des classes et
hors des classes ça ça suppose une vraie
concertation
ça suppose aussi que les enseignants
soient écoutés par leurs chefs
d'établissement parce que parfois il ya
des profs qui en fait ne savent pas
faire qui se font malmener
je ne sais pas si c'est le cas de cette
enseignante mais qu'ils ne le disent pas
parce qu'ils ont honte
en fait de simplement pas pouvoir tenir
leurs classiques te ment donc il ya
vraiment c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui se travaille en interne
plus que des mesures de voilà deux
gendarmes d'ailleurs ça c'est déjà fait
c'est pas une nouveauté même à nice
d'ailleurs estrosi avait voulu m
on dit un gendarme je prends un certain
certains policiers n'ont lancé que il ya
ce sujet des violences purement dans
l'enceinte scolaire dont vous venez de
parler et puis ce débat a été l'occasion
de prod2 proposition un peu plus large
de l'opposition peut-être ce sont la
surenchère sécuritaire auxquels vous
faisiez allusion à l'instant alors il ya
eu deux propositions faites par
l'opposition
la première était de supprimer les
allocations familiales pour les parents
dont où les mères seules dont les
enfants sont pris pour des faits de
délinquance voici la réponse de
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur c'était hier sur rtl
et cette réponse c'est non deuxième
sujet qui est celle de de supprimer ou
de diminuer les allocations familiales
oui moi je crois que c'est la double
peine c'est la double peine pour les
mères isolées
celle qui justement ont beaucoup de mal
au quotidien à tenir l'éducation de
leurs enfants leurs enfants leur échappe
et alors avant de continuer notre tour
de table une autre réaction
ministérielle à une autre proposition
celle ci elle était faite entre autres
par valérie pécresse qui était d'
abaisser la majorité pénale à 16 ans
nicole belloubet été la garde des sceaux
était invité du grand jury dimanche
dernier et je lui ai posé la question
faut-il abaisser la majorité pénale à 16
ans et la réponse là encore c'est non
vous savez moi je crois que beaucoup
d'élus sont demandeurs de réforme de la
loi pénale comme d'autres sont accros à
la drogue dure
moi je ne pense pas que la loi pénale
soit uniquement là pour faire changer
les choses c'est souvent dans la
pratique dans l'opérationnalité que
c'est important que vous allez couture
au moins il est cohérent le discours du
gouvernement et en gros chaque ministre
dit ben non non pas trop fort dans la
fonction et les cohérent a posteriori il
n'a pas été cohérent embryons et je peux
me permettre c'est parce que je suis
toujours bienveillant de pouvoir c'est
ce qu'on a vécu c'est quand même la
première manifestation de couac c'est
tout de même un ministre de l'intérieur
qui arrivent et qui trouve avec cet
incident assez hors cac taboye
dramatique dans une dans un
établissement scolaire à créteil
où cette profession se fait menacer par
mme fut-elle fakty je pense qu'elle a
pensé qu'elle était vrai je pense que
personne n'en a voulu être à sa place
christophe castaner sony c'est
formidable mais voilà mise de
l'intérieur je veux pouvoir faire une
annonce absolument tonitruante et je me
tout de suite je fais exploser une bombe
médiatique
résultat des courses il se fait recadrer
par l'ensemble du gouvernement nicole
belloubet naturellement dit que ce n'est
pas possible que l établissement
scolaire sont pas des camps de
redressement blanc caire fait du surf
avec une intelligence et une subtilité à
nulle autre pareille
une fine et c'est quand même un couac
c'est quand même un couac
et ce n'est pas très clair sur un sujet
aussi grave
je trouve que ce n'est pas très brillant
alors oui bien sûr on peut considérer
que ce n'est pas du tout la mesure
idoine pour résoudre un problème qui est
le problème de la viande et de colère
qui monte je trouve que moi j'ai eu qui
est professeur agrégé qui enseigne dans
les collèges dans des zones difficiles
et à sa demande
honnêtement bien sûr le barycentre a
changé ce qui fait que l'on ne doit pas
augmenter réellement là les plaindre de
professeurs considérant que bien sûr
parce que le barycentre se déplacer mais
que globalement la violence à l'école
elle elle l'a augmentée évidemment de
manière assez dramatique et donc pas
partout pas dans l'ensemble des
établissements scolaires
il y a aujourd'hui une problématique qui
n'existait pas il ya 20 ans qui existait
déjà un peu il ya dix ans qui sait ça
pue accéléré et qui n'est pas traitée
elle n'est pas traitée parce que
évidemment la hiérarchie de
l'institution scolaire a toujours aidé
ou d'ailleurs le hashtag pas de vagues
layachi de l'institution scolaire s'est
mise en en ordre de marche pour essayer
d'atténuer ou de rendre les choses un
peu invisible premier point le second
point et puis c'est une éminence si on
le sait tous les syndicats ont été non
en matière d'éducation nationale
les promoteurs de l'affectation des
professeurs en fonction de ce que l'on
pouvait considérer comme étant une
récompense pour eux donc c'est plus
facile d'avoir d'être professeur dans un
collège d'une zone favorisés que dans
une zone extrêmement défavorisées d'où
le fait que les plus jeunes professeurs
plutôt inexpérimentés se sont trouvés
dans des zones difficiles et ça c'est un
vrai problème que l'éducation nationale
n'a pas voulu traiter et qui est l'un
des moteurs de ce problème alors vous
pose la question sur twitter
chers internautes qui est en train de
suivre notre émission est ce que le
grondement est assez sévère sur ces
violences des jeunes à vous nous
répondez non à 87%
évidemment c'est pas un sondage puisque
c'est vous qui décidez ou non de vous
prononcer frédéric dabi est ce que
globalement dans internautes ils sont en
phase avec l'opinion ou bien est-ce
qu'ils sont un petit peu plus sévère au
répressif j'ai parfois l'habitude de
venir danser vos votes des internautes
qui sont des simples consultations sans
représentativité avec des enquêtes
contre précision tout à fait vous le
faites de manière très élégante bravo
mais là il ya une vraie convergence avec
ce qu'on observe dans l'état de
l'opinion publique française le contexte
général
c'est une très forte remontée depuis que
la menace terroriste est un petit peu
plus en deçà de la préoccupation sur la
question sécuritaire et c'est vrai qu'il
s'est passé à créteil
on l'a vu dans des enquêtes
quantitatives dans le baromètre match ça
a été le deuxième sujet dont les
français ont le plus parlé et dans les
enquêtes qualitatives
ça a été un coup de salah est un coup de
semonce pour beaucoup de français pas
seulement des parents avec l'idée que
l'idée de l'école comme un sanctuaire
c'est complètement fissurée et c'est
dans l'imaginaire des français
ce qui est particulièrement notable
alors de ceux de ce point de vue là les
le report du plan au 15 décembre
le fait que le gouvernement dise non à
toute une série de mesures peut-être
peut-être interprété comme une sorte de
spectacle de l'impuissance du
gouvernement sur ces sur ces questions
d'un côté l'opinion est extrêmement
sévère de l'autre qui est assez
intéressant c'est que aussi bien mme
belloubet que christophe castaner
reprennent dès lé refus du gouvernement
socialiste de l'époque notamment
christiane taubira de suppression des
allocations familiales et d'abaissement
la majorité pénale à 16 ans on se
souvient de joux se souvient d'une joute
verbale à l'assemblée nationale
notamment en phase avec ce tee gaspard
cancer à l'époque on avait employé le
mot laxisme pour christiane taubira
c'est pas le cas un port pour le
gouvernement actuellement en tout cas
dans les dents les commentaires qu'on
peut voir mais il ya quand même un
danger
je pense que la première chose que je
vais quand même vous dire c'est que
l'école est le reflet de la société donc
la violence monte dans la société comme
ça a été fort justement dit juste avant
moi il ya de l'insécurité qui progresse
et ne pas le dire ce serait un vrai
problème donc il faut commencer par
nommer les choses comme on dit la
violence qui a dans les établissements
scolaires existe les enseignants ils
sont confrontées elles existent aussi en
dehors des établissements scolaires il
faut y faire face et en faire une
priorité
on peut critiquer françois hollande le
gouvernement socialiste
or en matière de lutte contre
l'insécurité ils ont fait beaucoup ils
ont notamment rétabli les effectifs de
la police nationale et la gendarmerie
nationale qui avait été baissé par les
gouvernements précédents ils ont fait un
effort sans précédent pour lutter contre
le terrorisme mais malheureusement tout
n'a pas été réglé et la violence a
conduit à une province et donc s il faut
faire aujourd'hui
moi je ne crois pas aux vieilles aux
vieilles recettes des recettes toujours
les mêmes la droite agite en permanence
la suppression des allocations
familiales ou autres prestations en cas
de violences commises par des enfants
elle ne le fait jamais même quand on est
au pouvoir c'est que visiblement
évidemment il n'y croit pas elle même et
d'autres solutions toutes faites sortie
pochettes surprises comme celle ci non
je crois qu'il faut traiter les
problèmes à leurs racines donc
l'insécurité culturel et social qui peut
causer ces problèmes là et puis être
inflexible implacable face à ceux qui
les vident la route du droit et qui
commettent ces violences dans les
établissements et en dehors des
établissements moi je ne crois pas du
tout qu'on puisse mettre des policiers
dans les établissements construits s'en
sortira jamais c'est inefficace et non
pertinents en revanche autour des
établissements scolaires il faut faire
un effort et dans les établissements
il faut s'appuyer au maximum sur tous
ces adultes
ces adultes relais c'est un grand frère
ces contrats aidés on les appellera
comme on veut qu'ils doivent venir aider
les professeurs et l'encadrement de
l'établissement dans ce travail de
discipline parce que oui il faut être
ferme avec tous ceux qui sont des
délinquants dans l'école et en dehors de
l'école
je reviens sur cette proposition de
l'abaissement de la majorité pénale à 16
ans on sait que globalement la justice
des mineurs elle a été organisée à la
sortie de la deuxième guerre mondiale et
beaucoup disent mais aujourd'hui les
laisser jeunes ils sont beaucoup plus
violents et donc on ne peut pas faire
comme si c'étaient encore des enfants
ça vous paraît un argument recevable ou
pas clair chartier alors pardon mais je
voulais je suis désolé de ne pas
enchaîner sur votre question mais je
voudrais quand même sûrement quand même
à voile après rien et je voulais quand
même faire un distinguo il ya une
différence entre le sentiment d'un
sécurité et la réalité de dire que la
violence scolaire à l'école augmente
pourquoi pas mais en fait on n'a pas
vraiment les chiffres pour le prouvez
moi quand je suivais ce sujet il ya 20
ans début des années 2000 eh ben on
avait des cas comme ça c'était
exactement mais je vais continuer donc
ces questions ces questions que l'on se
pose là c'était exactement les mêmes on
avait des cas et même plus spectaculaire
donc franchement c'est pas parce qu'un
élève est encore une fois enfin ça doit
être terrible pour l'enseignant mais je
veux dire on a eu des cas mais vraiment
beaucoup plus spectaculaire ce qui se
passe de ce que j'ai ce que je comprends
c'est que il y a dans certains
établissements
effectivement des situations plus aiguë
et parfois l'éducation nationale comme à
toulouse n'a pas répondu comme il le
fallait aux préoccupations très concrète
des enseignants ça oui mais sur le plan
global ça n'est pas du tout avéré alors
que les gens et ce sentiment là c'est un
peu comme l'immigration pourquoi pas
mais le fait est enfin je veux pas qu'on
dise aussi facilement que la violence à
l'école au monde j'ai par des serveurs
c'est un enregistrement je voulais
revenir sur le ressenti est vraiment
quand on voit les formulations qui sont
le plus haut puis sentiment senti que
l'insécurité augmente ce sont plus les
catégories traditionnelles de la droite
respectable c'est parce que ce sont
plutôt des parents d'élèves alors
puisque distingue pas de distinguo je
crois qu'on fait remettre un distinguo
entre la violence des actes de violence
recensés comme tels et la civilité au
quotidien je pense que ce que disait
qu'à spa est vrai juste la société
enregistre globalement une montée de la
violence
les réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs accélère
puisque on le voit bien
ça donne une autorisation puisque les
groupes qui s'est retrouvée qui se
retrouve sur les réseaux sociaux
s'autorise à des pratiques de violence
parce qu'ils sont autorisés par le fait
de ne plus être seul essai ça crée des
situations de la civilité dont les
professeurs se plaignent
donc effectivement faisant le distinguo
entre violence et incivilités médias
qu'il n'y a pas un changement
d'attitudes en 10 ou 15 ans voilà
un mot sur la majorité pénale personne
n'est pour l'abaissement de la majorité
pénale à 16 ans c'est à moi je suis
clairement contre il ya déjà comme vous
le savez des mineurs qui font l'objet de
mesures de privation de liberté un
n'oublions jamais il y avait parfois des
mineurs de 15 ans saison qui sont en
prison en centre éducatif fermé
soit parce que ça pourrait apporter de
plus bon cela présente aujourd'hui la
majorité déjà compte tenu du fait que la
grêle la majorité intellectuelle et
morale pour les raisons d'ailleurs
combien de sites de pointe et a tendance
à reculer
je prouve que moi je serai quasiment
favorable à rétablir les majorités
hamadé a annoncé qu'elle colère à chaque
fois la question telle poussée la
question des banlieues
bah oui aussi dans des villes au coeur
de paris et les affrontements de bandes
c'est dans paris mais dans les villes
petites et moyennes il ya aussi micro
montée des eaux merci
merci à tous quelques commentaires de
nos internautes à qui on va laisser le
dernier mot
nicole le dit il faut remettre une vraie
discipline en classe et ne pas accepter
que les parents s'en prennent aux
enseignants en cas de punition
le président qui nous dit la droite ne
rêve que de la droite ne rêve que d'une
est formé de sanctions trois petits
points lourdes sous-entendus et voilà
s'il nous dit l'ailé alors je suis
désolé j'ai mon écran qui ne tient pas
bien des cas spectaculaires ont toujours
existé c'est leur généralisation qui
pose problème et il y avait aussi
d'autres voilà d'un internaute qui est
plutôt favorable semble-t-il au à la
suppression des allocations familiales
qui dit les seules sanctions qui sont
efficaces pour responsabiliser les
parents sont celles qui touchent au
portefeuille
et ben voilà toute façon le débat on va
y revenir puisque le 15 décembre on aura
des nouvelles mesures sur ce sujet
ségolène royal publie cette semaine un
livre qui s'intitule ce que je peux
enfin vous dire au début de cet ouvrage
elle développe assez longuement tout ce
qu'elle a dû subir
parce qu'elle était une femme elle s'en
est expliqué ce matin chez nos confrères
de france inter le plus dur je pense
c'est d'être mis en cause dans son
intelligence d'être traitée de folle
c'est très fréquent des traitée de folle
de quelqu'un d'un l'incontrôlable est ce
que j'ai voulu décrire c'est ce qu'une
femme subit en politique et qu'un homme
ne subit pas alors le décrit très
longuement attendant dans le livre et
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
un partant de cette situation
personnelle elle fait un rapprochement
que j'ai trouvé assez audacieux entre le
combat contre le sexisme et le combat
écologiste si vous n'avez pas tout suivi
voici l'explication de texte c'est
toujours sur france inter le plus dur je
pense c'est d'être mis en cause dans son
intelligence d'être traitée de folle
c'est très très fréquent d'être traitée
de folle de quelqu'un d'un incontrôlable
est ce que j'ai voulu décrire c'est ce
qu'une femme subit en politique et qu'un
homme ne subit pas alors ça c'était la
séance de rattrapage parce que c'est
l'image qu'on a déjà vu on va donc
maintenant voir l'autre extrait celui
dans lequel ségolène royal explique
qu'il ya un parallèle entre le combat
écologiste et le combat contre les
violences faites aux femmes si sur le
parallélisme entre les deux je montre à
quel point il est étonnant de voir que
c'est le même vocabulaire et la terre
souillée la terre abîmé la terre viol et
la torture exploités comme les femmes
les femmes souiller les femmes à ben les
femmes abîmer les femmes violées serre
celles qui subissent des violences c'est
la même chose c'est-à-dire l'homme
prédateur prend la terre comme l'homme
prédateur prend la femme et c'est pour
ça que ces deux combats sont étroitement
liés voilà n'est pas encore que ceux qui
ont une voiture diesel sont aussi
l'auteur de violences faites aux femmes
et ça va peut-être venir qu'à 50 ça vous
être convaincu par ce cette
démonstration
je suis convaincu déjà parce que 10
c'est wayne royal sur les violences dont
elle fait l'objet et elle-même violence
verbale heureusement pas cysique enfin
je ne crois pas tout au long de sa gare
politique et je crois que la fait preuve
d'un courage exceptionnel pour réussir à
tenir bon dans toutes ces années
envisagé encore une nouvelle fois d'être
peut être candidate aux élections
européennes
parce que je crois qu'effectivement pour
une femme c'est plus difficile dans le
secteur politique de progresser j'ai été
surpris par ce parallèle entre on va
dire l'environnement est la cause
féministe mais je trouve intéressant
parce qu'il interpelle et comme tout ce
qui interpelle et qui fait réfléchir je
pense que ça va dans le bon sens et il
est assez vrai que peut-être qui on peut
trouver des parallèles entre la société
dite de la domination masculine des
clips arbres odieux et puisque les deux
les dégâts commis par l'homme industriel
mécanique vis-à-vis de la planète
je pense que ça mérite réflexion est en
tout cas elle ouvre une porte de nos
débats qui m'intéressent
chartier oui je suis assez d'accord avec
cette analyse pour moi ce qui est
intéressant dans les propos de ségolène
royal et son livre c'est que c'est un
témoignage finalement assez rare dans
son ampleur on a déjà entendu parler de
sexisme en politique m'enfin là quand on
quand on regarde toutes là toute la la
la la chaîne d'avanies sexy ce qu'elle a
dû subir c'est quand même assez
impressionnant meneuse de revue parce
qu'elle sait dans solide micro phénomène
de mode super nanny de la politique mais
reflètent hard
ça va quand même au delà de la robe à
fleurs qu'on reprochait à cécile duflot
dans l'hémicycle
et vraiment à lire tout ça ça m'a ça m'a
amené en mémoire une phrase du
commandant américain macarthur pendant
la guerre de corée qui disait derrière
chaque montagne
il y avait une nouvelle montagne c'est
vrai quand on se dit que vraiment elle a
eu quand même du courage de supporter
tout ça pendant tant d'années
mais quand même si tu peux plus me
permettre une remarque elle ne dit aucun
moment qu'elle est aussi une femme
politique redoutable tacticien hors pair
parfois manipulatrice ça n'est pas n'a
pas travaillé pour rien avec françois
mitterrand tôt que que elle même ne soit
pas non plus
on va dire une espèce de deux
personnages tous complètement pure ça ça
lui vient pas à l'esprit de le dire ben
oui mais enfin je vois pas le rapport en
fait entre le fait d'avoir effectivement
des réflexes de femmes politiques et de
se faire traiter de conne ou deux enfin
je ne vois pas ces deux choses très
différentes quoi commencer ça que l a
tué des attaques dur parce qu'elles
étaient durs elle-même mais enfin à ce
moment là les hommes ne subissent pas du
tout le même genre d'attaquant face
cette espèce de procès en incompétence
et beaucoup fait à l'endroit des femmes
est beaucoup moins à l'endroit des
hommes donc c'est ça qu'elle dénonce le
fait qu'elle soit une femme politique
par ailleurs et qu elle sache si prend
dès qu'elles soient parfois assez
énervante
enfin enfoncé tout ça tout ça sur ces
deux choses différentes je pense
franchement ces deux registres
différents je pense que aller à les
confondre
on rentre dans le jeu de ceux qui sont
tombés à bras raccourcis sur ségolène
est valable pendant tant d'années je
pense aussi que l'acte lourd si on
revient à la période historique de
2006-2007 séquelles et gagner cette
primaire semi-ouverte du parti
socialiste face à tout l'appareil du ps
face à deux candidats qui n'ont
complètement déligitimer il ya une
différence entre voici mon programme et
mon programme assez voici qui va garder
qui va garder les enfants c'est sérieux
la politique
les trois semaines de commentaires
notamment par la droite au moment de la
fameuse phrase le mot la bravitude sur
la muraille sur la muraille de chine et
elle a quand même fini avec 17 millions
de voix est là aussi il faut être
honnête
chedjou et de la distinction par rapport
à ses adversaires quand les en débat
face à dominique strauss kahn et laurent
fabius et on demande c'est quoi la
différence entre vous et eux elle dit ça
se voit et elle le dit ça mais ce qui
est vrai aussi c'est que les femmes
politiques qui ont eu du pouvoir ont été
aussi très fortement attaquées edith
cresson à leur serment à relativement
longtemps martine aubry anne hidalgo sur
la ville de paris maintenant c'est vrai
que c'est quelqu'un qui a une incidence
aussi également même si elle sait de
faceo va être intéressant est là - mais
elle a reçu mardi la fin dit ça suffit
la femme qui ce oui j'estime tout le
temps alors elle a fait un petit peu
elle est la puce jouer la proximité
identificatoires une femme divorcée qui
a élevé des enfants seuls elle a plutôt
elle a été sur un registre différent par
exemple de ségolène royal ces graines ce
livre sera aussi dans un moment
particulier elle envisage ou pas d'être
d'accepter la perche un peu désespérée
du ps comme tête de liste du parti
socialiste c'est quand même une
personnalité du point de vu de la
popularité socialiste qui a été au
pouvoir entre 2014 et 2017 qui échappe
au discrédit de beaucoup de ténors qui
n'a pas disparu et qui a un socle de
popularité très élevée chez les
sympathisants et électeurs dès
maintenant vous allez couture ségolène
royal ce livre de façon très personnelle
dans cet ouvrage est là explique combien
elle a souffert d'être d'être abandonné
la requête et on appellera ça comme on
voudra par françois hollande pour une
femme dix ans plus jeune que moi dit
elle est ce que vous trouvez que c'est
est ce un c'est souhaitable que il ya
comme ça un livre à la fois politique et
très personnelle est ce que ça dit
quelque chose de l'époque alors ça dit
quelque chose de ségolène royal
saisis pas forcément de l'époque ce qui
m'apparaît dans ce livre dans l'effort
quel hacker là qu'elle accomplit dans un
travail qui est à la fois peut-être un
tout petit peu par le biais de ses
confidences personnelles un peu trop
justement cette information est tout
petit peu grand public 1 et qui
s'apparente un peu à la télé réalité
entre guillemets et puis le travail
exceptionnel de résilience tel a fait
pendant toute sa carrière
et honnêtement ce livre il vient
sanctionner ça et je dirais c'est parce
que ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
parce qu'elle a été une femme politique
dure parce qu'elle a été capable de
manipulation au même titre que les
hommes politiques le peuple peuvent la
pratiquer c'est là que l'on voit que l a
souffert d'autant plus et que sa parole
et particulièrement à écouter c'est
parce qu'elle n'a pas subi même
traitement que ceux qui comme elle avait
de la politique une vision qui était
plutôt musclée certes mais l on lui a
fait payer
évidemment le fait d'être une femme
politique comme on le fait payer les
favoris parce que on le sait la
politique est un milieu horriblement dur
mais ce qu'on lui a fait payer en plus
d'être une femme et je trouve que ce
parallèle avec l'environnement même s'il
est audacieux il a ce mérite là se
mérite qui est de mettre en lumière que
des sujets cruciaux dans la société
son vécu en général avec un déni un déni
dont nous sommes parfois complices nous
gens de médias et que ce déni elle le
fracasse en mettant sur la table le fait
que non des enfants regarder la réalité
en face
maintenant qu'elle soit tête de liste
des socialistes pour les européennes
tant mieux ça prouve justement que on
n'aura pas réussi à la mettre à terre
qu'on n'aura pas réussi à la larguer en
au passage moi j'ajoute et je termine là
dessus je les ai vécus comme vous tous
mais il se trouve que baba ou de l'état
j'ai vécu de très près la campagne de
désinformation autour d'elle sur la
campagne présidentielle
c'était invraisemblable mais
invraisemblable
je n'ai jamais comme ça elle affole la
dague ses amis socialistes qui ont fait
publier un livre qui était une jeune
fille était en fait un pamphlet bref
contre elle donc honnêtement
honnêtement ce qu'elle a vécu aucun
homme politique ne l'a vécue de la même
manière et elle le doit au fait d'être
une femme
et pour ça moi je me sens tout à fait
solidaire bien que ne soit pas a priori
solidaire de ségolène royal sur un plan
politique mais je me sens solidaire cet
ouvrage et bien voilà qui est dit alors
faut être plus solidaires que nos
internautes à qui on a posé la question
êtes vous satisfait du retour de
ségolène royal vous nous répondez non à
60 k était parti t'es pas partie il nous
dit frédéric dabi alors anti mac nous
dit mais les hommes aussi subissent de
la violence en politique
voilà babines dis-moi bizarrement gmc
gaulle est de plus en plus et ben c'est
très bien bas vidéo et un autre
internaute r3 nous dit qu'y at-il de
positif dans le bilan du pouvoir région
ministère de ségolène royal alors ce
bilan malheureusement on manque un peu
de temps pour le faire
mais effectivement vous êtes dehors
d'avoir parlé c'est vrai elle a un grand
projet qui est probablement de prendre
une tête de liste peut être élargie aux
européennes avec les socialistes et les
écologistes en tout cas il ya beaucoup
de gens qui souhaitent ça et parmi eux
il ya françois kalfon qui est l'un des
patrons du parti socialiste est alors
lui il est fan vous allez voir et je le
dis ce matin à monsieur jadot à benoît
hamon à dos des personnalités regroupons
nous c'est une urgence absolue
je crois que ségolène royal peut
incarner ce rassemblement des gauches
ségolène royal incarne l'écologie
populaire une écologie enthousiaste et
non pas finalement un coup de rabot
fiscal contre les français et toc
un coup contre l'augmentation des taxes
sur le diesel gaspard granger vous
pensez que c'est une bonne idée c'est
vrai est tête de liste
oui comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour elle son
courage sa résilience et son combat pour
l'écologie depuis toujours mais on verra
ce que décident les socialistes je ne
suis plus membre de ce parti je trouve
dramatique que en trente ans cela fait
trente ans c'est normal avec la
politique est socialiste n'ait pas été
capable de se renouveler suffisamment de
10,2
trouver des candidats ne se renouveler
en leur sein pour trouver quelqu'un pour
porter les couleurs des socialistes aux
élections européennes qui auront lieu en
c'est l'échec du parti socialiste parce
que la première fonction d'un parti
politique c'est de sélectionner des
candidats et d'identifier des
personnalités quand on est obligé
d'aller chercher ségolène royal qui a
été élu pour la première fois à
l'assemblée nationale en 1988
c'est un problème elle reproche dans ce
la fragrance oui c'est pas mieux en fins
et puis moi je ne supporte plus je suis
désolé on va me taxer de jeuniste je
suis moins en moins jeunes j'ai 39 ans
et c'est assez dire mais je veux
vraiment c'est insupportable qui est
toujours la même génération politique
qui aujourd'hui a allègrement dépassé la
soixantaine qui trustent les postes et
c'est pas parce qu'on a un président de
la république qu'il ya une quarantaine
d'années que c'est le mouzon empêché de
conduire ce renouvellement
dans ce livre on le disait à l'instant
elle reproche un de gaspard kranzer
assez fortement à françois hollande son
attitude en 2007 quand il l'a quittée
pour une autre femme
ça vous paraît normal de parler de ça
dans un livre quand on est un mois la
consacre politique ans je pense qu'avoir
chacun fait ce qu'il veut mais la vie
privée doit doit rester privé j'avais
été choqué par le bouquin de valérie
trierweiler sur sur françois hollande
merci pour ce moment je vois pas
l'intérêt de dévoiler des éléments qui
dès qu'ils relèvent de la vie privée et
de l'intimité d'un couple
voilà je trouve je trouve ça dommage
après malheureusement c'est devenu
monnaie courante et je pense qu'on
gagnerait à faire preuve de davantage de
pudeur en la matière noble sauf que
c'est aussi conscient de ces événements
real c'est public mais les prix réels
des objets de remettre sur la table un
système parallèle on à en souligner tout
ce qui dans le livre quand même foutu de
notation qui a vécu à ce moment là elle
a vécu la chose avec mais on l'imaginé
on imagine que ça a été terrible et très
triste et dangereux nous surinvesti sont
ceux qui dans le livre n'a pas une bonne
d'importance fondamentale
frédéric dabi les français sont
sensibles à ce genre de confidences
alors ça peut faire gagner en proximité
ça dépend l'homme ou la femme politique
un camp florent fa bu dans un lit disait
qu'il aimait beaucoup les balades en
montagne et les carottes râpées ça n'a
pas changé grand chose à la popularité
qui qui dont ils pâtissent et auprès des
français ségolène royal ya un vrai lien
auprès des français c'est quand même
n'oublions pas 17 millions de voix au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
puisque nicolas sarkozy en 2012 quand il
a été battu beaucoup plus bien sûr que
marine le pen en 2010 est maintenant les
français opère une distinction très
forte entre vie privée et vie publique
ils n'attendent pas des français d du
personnel politique des confessions
genre sachant qu' on ne sait on se
souvient du communiqué de la fpf
au soir du second tour des élections
législatives comme le ps
grâce à la tva sociale ray transforme
une défaite humiliante en simple en
simple défaite je pense les français
sont passés depuis très longtemps à
autre chose ils sont peut-être de
salaire royal des propositions par
exemple sont en europe est plus une
vision parce que ils n'ont pas à en
tirer
elle a échappé je pense aux dégagisme
alors qu'elle n'était pas candidate en
2017 elle avait été battue on se
souvient tragiquement en 2012 mais il ne
la voit pas comment j'ai des voitures
non parce que je pense qu'elle a une
vraie capacité pour entrer en résonance
avec la sensibilité populaire est par
exemple là on le voit avec ce livre je
regardais le tweet de votre journaliste
en effet on est dans une période mitu
donc il est de bon ton il est justifié
de parler des femmes victimes
ça colle aussi avec l'idée aujourd'hui
d'une époque où finalement les héros se
sont pas les gens forts mais plutôt les
gens plus vulnérables qui résistent qui
sont résilients donc là on est
complètement dans l'air du temps elle
avait lancé en 2007 elle avait eu une
intuition géniale elle avait lancé une
plateforme participative de 2006 qui est
exactement l avait anticipé avant les
autres donc ce côté collaboratif donc en
fait elle a un pif incroyable et je
pense que c'est ça c'est proximité là
qui lui donne à mon sens une capacité de
rebond en effet politique et on a
entendu avec ses déclarations sur la
hausse du diesel qui ont eu un impact
énorme ces derniers jours on passe à un
autre responsable politique et peut-être
un tout petit peu moins en forme
notre président la république emmanuel
macron vous savez que le conseil des
ministres a commencé le mercredi
eh bien cette fois ci c'était hier car
le président va prendre trois jours de
vacances tout ça et peut-être
complètement normal ou alors
ça ne l'est pas dans l'opposition on
trouvait que peut-être le président
devrait être plus présent ça énerve
beaucoup gabriela talent c'est un
nouveau secrétaire d'état il est chargé
de la jeunesse et l'a dit ce matin sur
france info
ouais là franchement je vous avoue que
quand je vois ce débat depuis hier sur
le break de trois jours du président de
la république je me dis franchement on
est un peu chez les dingues on a vu j'ai
vu une intervention de christian jacob
qui est quand même président du premier
groupe d'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale les républicains qui parlait
de ça pendant 20 secondes à autre chose
à dire sur les réformes pendant ses
portes et honnêtement je trouve ça
totalement
or seuls alors peut-être que c'est hors
sol ou peut-être que le président n'a
public a tellement laissé entendre qu'il
était exceptionnel qui dormaient que
quelque sorte par nuit que du coup on
est presque surpris de le voir
ben il ya besoin de repos que la
chartier moi je trouve que ça dans cet
aveu de fatigue en fait en quelque sorte
c'est une façon de reconnaître qu'il a
été marqué par une séquence extrêmement
pénible pour lui depuis la rentrée
de la même façon ça m'a fait penser à
son allocution à l'occasion du
remaniement où il a reconnu que ces
expressions pouvait être mal perçu que
son comportement vis-à-vis des élus
locaux étaient pas non plus celui qu'il
fallait donc il a rectifié le tir
donc sans faire de commentaire de
parallélisme mitterrandien un peu
malvenu je trouve que on voit là une
sorte de force tranquille en fait parce
qu'on sait bien qu'il faut être fort
pour pour admettre ses failles ses
faiblesses et là en fait il le fait et
sur le fond il là je trouve qu'il a
plutôt raison de ralentir le rythme
parce que la frénésie
jamais bonne conseillère et en plus vu
ce qui s'annonce avec la campagne des
européennes aussi important de conseil
et on en interne le monde des coq à sa
politique fixée à fiscale je pense que
c'est plutôt justifié légitime est
plutôt malin casper cancer on a un peu
oublié il faisait des breaks comme ça
aussi françois hollande où vous savez
que françois hollande il a vécu un été
2012 à plus ou moins épouvantable il a
pris quelques jours de vacances et il
s'est fait très fortement critiqué pour
ses vacances donc résultat il n'a plus
pris aucune vacance pendant tout le
reste du quinquennat
moi je me souviens quand je suis arrivé
à l'elysée c'était un jeudi le vendredi
soir j'allais le voir dire à lundi m'a
dit à demain le samedi soir j'allais le
voir pour lui dire à lundi m'a dit à
demain ne s'est pas arrêté pendant trois
ans il ne s'est jamais plaint je ne m'en
suis jamais plaint pourquoi parce que
quand on est au service de la france on
au service des français
on donne son temps 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 pendant l'intégralité de son
mandat personne n'avait forcer ni
nicolas sarkozy ni françois hollande ni
emmanuel macron à postuler à l'élection
présidentielle et une fois qu'ils y sont
ils doivent le faire à fond jusqu'au
bout évidemment comme dans un marathon
il faut savoir ménager ses forces et on
a bien le droit de se reposer même de
dormir de temps en temps mais je trouve
qu ils veulent macro et aussi un peu
puni par là où il a péché quelle mise en
scène nous avons eu le droit au
président qui ne dort jamais cette force
herculéenne qui n'a pas bu qui peut se
déployer partout sur le globe en
habitant et puis on a eu aussi le droit
des images des vacances à des images du
week-end avant la campagne etc
il faut pas ce faux pas s'étonner
aujourd'hui qu'on s'intéresse à son
break
parce que lui même et son entourage ont
mis en scène de façon perpétuelle le
président sportif qui fait du vélo qui
fait du foot etc
donc il est puni par là où il a péché
bon et bien comme la température baisse
ça tombe bien puisque le voilà habillé
pour l'hiver
c'est beau comme l'antique autres
partage pas ce point de vue donc je
pense que le président de la république
qui prennent trois jours et que ça fasse
l'objet de débats nombreux depuis
l'annnonce de ces de ces trois jours me
semble grotesque mais vraiment grotesque
pourquoi parceque il fait effectivement
un travail de président avec un style
original
moi j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer à
sion ce sujet mais il dirige la force
comme on dirige une entreprise plus que
comme un homme politique et donc il est
dans une espèce d'obsession du résultat
de la réforme du travail
et effectivement il nous a fait savoir
qu'ils bossaient 21h sur 24 et que
évidemment la presse avide de sensations
fortes et ravi lorsque sur un
comportement une attitude une forme de
2,2 d'expression personnelle qui est
orthogonale par rapport à cette image de
premier classe parfait le chef
d'entreprise qui gouverne la france
absolument comme si c'était une
multinationale
tout cela la presse lui tombe dessus je
trouve ça franchement hors de propos bon
il a un coup de fatigue c'est vrai que
la rentrée a pas été facile
il s'est tapé de la sphère benalla qui
était avant la rentrée
jusqu'à la démission de colons en
passant par celle du lot c'est impartial
de l'eau effectivement les problèmes
autour de la sécurité parfois il
il a un travail devenant la république
et il est effectivement fatigue et
j'imagine de l'ensemble de ce qu'il a à
faire mais ce que je crois et qui
n'était pas tout à fait le cas ses
prédécesseurs c'est il a pris la pleine
mesure du quinquennat lui et que
matignon et à l'elysée une bonne fois
pour toutes voilà et donc il le fait il
dirige ce pays comme un premier ministre
plus communs penda république
il a deux boulots c'est aussi l'argent
on disait ça de sarkozy sarkozy mais je
trouve que emmanuel macron pousse la
logique encore un cran plus loin edouard
philippe se planquent si je puis dire un
petit peu moins
que françois fillon aussi vous donner la
parole
je voulais vivre livre juste pardon des
témoignages d'internautes cij qui nous
disent qu'ils étaient très juste ce ne
sont pas ces vacances qui sont
étonnantes
mais le fait que ça n'avait pas l'air
anticipé et c'est vrai qu'au début on a
même dit que le conseil des ministres
était avancé à mardi parce que le
président d'avic avait un engagement
officiel ensuite anti mac nous dit je
pense qu'il nous fait une grosse déprime
et arcus guen nous dit il peut avoir
besoin de se reposer mais il peut le
faire avec plus de discrétion la même si
c'est vrai qu objectivement c'est plus
nous les médias qui parlent donc ses
vacances que lui qui les a annoncé
frédéric dabi est ce que vous pensez que
les français vous reprochez à macro de
partir en vacances comme il l'avait
reproché à françois hollande à l'été de
nombreuses comme le rappelait les spurs
je pense lui reprocher il ya des
critiques beaucoup plus compliqué pour
lui en termes la justice de sa politique
en termes de 10 ans par rapport aux
préoccupations des français en terme de
résultats notamment sur le pouvoir
d'achat
je n'en sais un petit peu ce gaspard
grandeur à 10 en 2012 françois hollande
il ya eu quelques propos sur ses
vacances c'est moins ces vacances qui
ont été empochés que le sentiment qu'ils
avaient pas pris la mesure de la
fonction notamment au moment du plan de
licenciements annoncés pour psa et
notamment la surprise du choc fiscal
annoncé le 9 septembre 2012 sur tf1 ou
voilà les français avaient été
complètement décontenancé que ce n'était
pas dans sa campagne présidentielle
maintenant je donne raison on est quand
même merci je pense qu'on est quand même
sur une construction médiatique
rappelez vous après le 14 juillet 2009
comme nicolas sarkozy avait fait un
petit malaise après à food inc il y
avait aussi tout un emballement
médiatique sûr il y avait épuisé le
président super héros donc je pense que
on n'est pas sur des sujets qui vont
impacter d'opinion publique il paraît
qui part en vacances en normandie les
informations en week-end en week-end par
dont fabrice hilton avait quand même
mois les vagues rendent les week-ends
qui commencent le mercredi soir excusez
moi il fait le bombo figaro c'est pas
comme ça
le prix fait le banc il fait le point à
vrai dire nous aussi pour tout à fait
honnête je crois même qu'il y aura pas
de point de vue le jour de la toussaint
donc et bien habile transition comme
bien de faire remarquer très aimablement
que la charte et avec le dernier sujet
demain c'est la toussaint la fête où
l'église catholique et ses membres
honorent leur sein aujourd'hui c'est
halloween est une fête qui nous vient de
des états unis et qu'il était encore un
qui était encore inconnu il ya 20 ou 30
ans halloween la toussaint qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire est ce que
ces défaites que vous avez envie de
fêter est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que les français ont un rapport avec
leurs défunts qui est qui a changé
question ouverte parce que le sujet est
aussi celui qu'elle veut parler pendant
qu'à cet âge encaissé une question très
cher à 16
moi je célèbre comme nous dormons
catholique puisque je suis catholique la
toussaint en allant voir mclean et deux
sur la tombe de mes proches ceux de ma
famille qui nous ont qui nous ont
quittés mes enfants je dois le
reconnaître mes quatre enfants eux ce
qui les intéresse c'est halloween et
nous en parle depuis approuvé trois
semaines des déguisements des bonbons
etc et on voit que la mondialisation
culturelle elle est même plus une
question elle est totalement là et eux
c'est ce qui les intéresse ils le voient
comme une opportunité pour faire la fête
et mangeaient des sucreries
alors ce que j'ai fait ce que j'ai vu en
préparant les missions c'est qu'en fait
le
il ya là tous inquiets la fête de tous
les saints dans les gens qui sont
reconnus comme ça oui ou qui sont
inconnus et puis ensuite il ya le
dimanche qui suit et vous xavier couture
vous allez vous costumer ce soir en
sorcière bien sûr c'est mon costume
c'est mon beau film habituel mais
j'aurais pas osé je le fais pour vous
mais ce qui me frappe c'est que d'une
certaine façon c'est l'envahissement
laïque dans ce qui a été le l'espace
religieux là qu'on fait il y as autour
de cette idée de la célébration des
morts avec la toussaint une fête était
effectivement comme zéga ce pas une fête
qui amenait le lendemain de la toussaint
sur les cimetières
avant on allait bordés quelques
chrysanthèmes sur la tombe de nos
anciens à noter enfin on voit bien
qu'avec halloween c'est l'entrée d'une
certaine culture américanisé de la
célébration religieuse qui se laïciser
qui se commercialisent d'ailleurs
halloween est un formidable film de john
carpenter qui est extraordinaire qui
ressort il va là c'est à une nouvelle
version qui ressort est donc on voit
bien qu'il ya autour de 7 noeuds ce
rapport à la mort une volonté non plus
de célébrer les défunts mais d'affirmer
le vivant c'est à dire que je suis
vivant et je me déguise en eau pour vous
montrer bien pour montrer à quel point
je suis vivant je me moque de la mort
mais je vous la caf de la main c'est
d'ailleurs ça ramène à cette fête
formidable qui a lieu au mexique
le week-end dernier et qu'une fête de
2,2 effectivement on se déguise en
squelette en se déguisant mort justement
pour s'en moquer pour affirmer un trône
et filière se moque de la mort mais nous
laisse cavadee actuellement moi je vois
plutôt ça comme ça c'est à dire comme un
escamotage en fait de la mort plus et
vêtements seront en fait on choisit avec
halloween de préférer effectivement la
fête la fête la vie à la mort qui était
bon la toussaint la célébration des 100
initialement et ensuite après des
défunts donc à mon avis c'est plutôt ça
que ça reflète et en plus ça correspond
à l'évolution d'effectivement des
pratiques funéraires aujourd'hui puisque
la crémation monte en puissance si je
peux dire ya à peu près un tiers des
français me semble-t-il qui sont
favorables à sa qui est une pratique qui
a été
monti existe l'exister antiquités qui a
été remise un petit peu sur le dans le
débat public à la révolution puis en
fait qui est reparti depuis les années
70 et aujourd'hui on voit bien que ça
séduit de plus en plus de français parce
que derrière ça moi je suis je pense
qu'il y a quand même
outre le fait qu'il ya beaucoup moins de
pratique et la fois effectivement tu en
as a reflué
il ya aussi l'idée que on se débarrasse
assez vite du problème c'est à dire que
bon bah et même les défunts enfin les
les gens qui veulent qu'ils disent
qu'ils veulent se faire enfin fini est
incinéré de 7 à soi c'est aussi parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas de poser plus de
problèmes que ça à ceux qui restent donc
on voit bien qu'il ya derrière ça l'idée
que la mort bas on va vite de l'expédier
on va vite l'expédier quoi donc je pense
que ça reflète sa façade avez-vous
qu'ils connaissent et les français comme
personne alors c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
mais juste depuis une quarantaine
d'années on si on pose une question qui
est préférée vous être enterrés ou
crématisé c'est-à-dire incinérés dans 79
qui avait que 20 % des français qui
souhaitaient être incinéré il ya eu un
basculement dans les années 2006 2008 je
sais pas pourquoi ces années là où
maintenant le fait de vouloir être
incinérés et majoritaire pour la
dernière fois s'est déposée pour express
en début d'année 2010 8 et c'était 47%
des français avec un clivage vient en
fait bien sûr générationnel extrêmement
prononcée comme le fait de vouloir fêter
halloween versus la puissance est
d'abord une question d'âge et une petite
parenthèse la catégorie la plus
réfractaire à fêter halloween ce sont
les catholiques pratiquants qui voit
cette pratique comme une invasion de
leur foi dont 47% être incinérés et 29%
être enterrée est pour l'heure assez
indifférent 2006-2010 et voudrait dire
qu'il ya un impact de la défaite de
ségolène royal où la crise financière
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy halloween
si vous me disiez c'est une c'est une
coutume américaine anglo saxon oui c'est
une cuillère en fait
mais qui a été qui a été récupérée vous
me disiez parle par le cinéma américain
c'est c'est une un site comme un autre
de l'américanisation de la culture
française ou bien il ya vous y voyez
même un sens plus fort que celui là je
crois qu'il y a le sens qui a été
effectivement très très justement d'y
exposer mais je pense qu'il est tout de
même dans cette espèce de volonté de
célébrer halloween c'est entrer par les
fast food à l'origine en france c'est
une mare d'eau qui avait importé
halloween et donc je pense qu'il ya
quand même une puissance de l'économie
américaine de la culture américaine la
culture populaire américaine qui est
entrée avec avec cette célébration si
terrible de résister à ça quand on a des
enfants fin vous de l'évoquer c'est
infernal en fait tu as perdu 63 la
lecture le retour de c1 mardi gras de
mort alors on va laisser la parole à nos
internautes
il ya philosophe qui nous dit moi je ne
fait aucun des deux comme ça au moins
c'est au moins c'est clair
on l'applaudît c'est une fête pour les
enfants comme pour comme noël et olympe
encore elle qui le dit ma petite fille
de 16 ans fête halloween et ignorent
même que ses ascendants sont et ignorent
même pardon ses ascendants qui sont au
cimetière mashiro l'un peut-être cette
occasion d'aller faire faire
connaissance et après tout pas
d'exclusive on peut peut-être fêter
halloween et la toussaint merci beaucoup
à tous les quatre d'avoir accepté notre
invitation point de vue c'est terminé
pour ce soir mais l'émission continue
demain même heure même endroit
merci beaucoup
[Musique]